الناشط هو ابرز السجناء مصر السياسيين
علاء عبد الفتاح يخدع لاجراءات طبيه بعلم
جهات قانونيه بحسب ما نقلت والدته عن
السلطات المصريه شقيقه المعتقل غردت
مستنكره عدم اخطار العائله او محامي
شقيقها خلال الاجراءات ولا سيما وان عبد
الفتاح اعلن اضرابا كاملا عن الطعام
والماء منذ ايام تزامنا مع افتتاح مؤتمر
المناخ الذي تستضيفه بلاده لكن النيابه
العامه المصريه اصدرت بيانا تشكك فيه
باضراب عبد الفتاح وتقول انها امرت بتشكيل
لجنه طبيه متخصصه لاجراء كشف طبي له وان
تقريرا لجنه النهائي يفيد بان حالته
الصحيه جيده محامي عبد الفتاح كان قد نشر
قبيل ذلك مدونه يقول فيها ان السلطات سجن
وادي النطرون حيث يقنع علاء لم تسمح
بزيارته رغم صدور تصريح بذلك
سجن وادي النطرون من نهايه شهر خمسه لم
يتم التصريح لم يتم السماح لي بزيارته رغم
تصحي منيابه ده رقم واحد رقم اثنين بيان
النيابه العامه اليوم اللي صدر منذ قليل
جاء به ان اسره علاء عبد الفتاح تمكنت من
زيارته يوم 07/11 وهذا كلام غير حقيقي
للاسف اخر مره كما كانت فيها الدكتوره
ليلى سويس زياره علاء كان يوم 24/10
منظمات الحقوقيه وانسانيه ومنها المبادره
المصريه لحقوق الفرديه عبرت عن خشيتها من
فرض السلطات المصريه تغذيه قصريه على
وعشيه وصول الرئيس الامريكي الى شرم الشيخ
حيث ينعقد مؤتمر كوب 27 تستمر التعبئه
للمطالبه بالافراج عن السجناء السياسيين
في مصر البيت الابيض السابق وصول الرئيس
الامريكي باعرابه عما وصفه بقلقه حيل وضع
عبد الفتاح فيما افاد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي بان بايدا سيبحث قضايا حقوق
الانسان مره رئيس المصري خلال المؤتمر